avec un peu d'imagination on pourrait se
prendre pour robinson crusoé redevenus
sauvages porquerolles sort de l'été avec
douceur les derniers estivants jouent
aux naufragés volontaires dans une sorte
de paradis où le temps s'est arrêté pris
service fréquentation c'est donc l'heure
des bilans
et une fois n'est pas coutume les
commerçants seraient presque satisfait
c'est une saison qui a débuté timidement
sur le mois de juillet et s'est
confirmée sur le mois d'août avec une
participation de des touristes sur l'île
de porquerolles
mais dans l'ensemble on peut dire que
c'est une saison qui s'est relativement
bien passée un signe ne trompe pas à
bord de l'amour des îles le bateau qui
relie porquerolles au continent les
arrivants se comptent encore par
centaines autour du 15 août près de 4000
personnes débarquées ainsi chaque jour
sur l'île un cinquième de plus que l'an
dernier bien placé pour observer le
phénomène
l'office de tourisme et la baye qui
déferle à tout moment la corde coloré de
ceux qui ont quelque chose à demande il
ya eu polonais peut-être des russes des
allemands et beaucoup d'italiens
alléchés par des taux de change plus
avantageux les étrangers sont de retour
invasion pacifique acp grand tour de
vélo
le seul moyen de transport autorisé ici
la durée moyenne du séjour une semaine
permet de découvrir les plus beaux
panoramas et inciterait certains a
refusé la rentrée